[Musik]
wann waren sie zuletzt so richtig in der
natur haben sie da vielleicht sogar
bäume umarmt oder haben sie sich mal
überlegt ob all diese pflanzen um uns
herum vielleicht kommunizieren ja gar
fühlen können wenn sie jetzt abwinken
dann hören sie mal was meine heutigen
gäste darüber wissen
herzlich willkommen der sternstunde
religion heute geht es hier um die natur
und darum was wir menschen für ein
komplexes verhältnis zu ihr haben
[Musik]
natürlich sie sind frost ingenieuren
haben nicht deswegen hier an den rand
der berliner schlucht eingeladen um ihr
einige besonderheiten hier zu zeigen
mitunter eben diese aber bisher ganz
bekannt dafür dass es ein heiliger baum
ist und interessant wenn es um bezahlte
natur geht was hat denn dieser baum so
spezielles an sich ja die eibe ist der
baum der wirklich außerhalb des
gewöhnlichen steht es ist ein baum der
extrem vital ist und praktisch
unsterblich wenn man in mir angeschaut
sieht und versteht wieder wächst und er
wurde als solcher erkannt oder wirklich
als bindeglied zwischen der physischen
welt und auch scheinig derweil dahinter
ich wahrgenommen unsichtbaren welt für
diese alten völker und zwar dass völker
keltische völker geben die ihren namen
von idol diego ohne ist das eigene volk
und die eu wies die einen krieger oder
dann hat das auch dilemma witzes gegeben
die ulmen krieger die einen krieger das
waren die kriege dank der kraft der
liebe und diese eben waren im zentrum
ihrer
religion oder ihres lebens und waren
dann auch immer verbunden mit diesen
alten stein setzungen die sogar auf hält
die schweiz mit diesen mega mieten
deswegen stehen die eigenen dann auch
bei alten kultstätten oder genau das hat
sie dann geschützt diese diese besondere
stellung
auch bei dieser 90 plätzen diese
verehrung als sie dann geschützt vor
allem
bäume fällen bei der christianisierung
und was würden sie sagen was ist das
ganz besondere dieses baumes das eben
eher als heilig angeschaut wurde und
nicht an andere so hier ist nimmt man
schon wieder aus sich selbst wieder
heraus wächst und so das ist vegetative
kraft und ganz alte bäume haben
eventuell einen so dicken stamm des
videos wird und dann können wir die
wurzeln im eigenen körper angelegt
werden und sogar will kann ja warum
eigentlich
über jahrtausende sich immer wieder
erneut kein schöneres bild für für
ewiges leben also neben nun droht die
sich verschmelzen oder zusammen wirken
hier sieht man effektiv hier sogar eine
unglaubliche vitalität kraft hat weil es
oft hat er einen sehr guten einfluss auf
den menschen in japan gibt es das bald
wagen haben sie auch schon zur spezielle
naturerfahrung gemacht ja ich bin
natürlich als kind in die bande
geklettert und dann die welt oder
standard und dann später immer mehr man
ja genau das gehört dazu aber auch
barfuß im wald genauso wichtig da kommt
elektrische kraft eigentlich in den
körper und auch übernachten im alter
freigegeben sind nicht jafry hindern
unter den baumkronen hinter nacht dann
zieht plötzlich schweine in der nähe
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
bei der halbe haben wir von heiligen
stätten gesprochen jetzt liegt hier ein
riesiger findling haben der baum und
dieser stein eine verbindung ja immer
auch dieser stein der ist von den
gletschern heran gebracht worden und
steht jetzt auf dem fels grund das war
ein sogenannter vaduz stein der
eigentlich früher einmal sich bewegen
ließ und verbindung mit den bäumen hat
das ganz bestimmt nicht weit von hier
hat einfach sehr viel solche schalen
das war für ihre opfer gabel bestimmt
ist ja wirklich auch bei heiligen
stätten dann bei heiligen stätten genau
diese ganze region ist eigentlich so
bekannt und diese steine mit ihrem
riesigen gewicht auf dieser unterlage
entwickeln auch eine form von energie
sogenannte bier zu elektrizität weil das
gewicht auf gewicht auf unterlagen
druckt ereignet ich auch eine art strom
freigibt und reagieren die bäume darauf
und die bäume regeln ganz bestimmt
darauf man kann elektronen an die beim
ersetzen und märkten wie ich sie
eigentlich bio elektrische ströme habe
und sie leiten auch elektrizität in den
brunnen also die steine und die bäume
haben auch ähnliche funktionen in diesem
sinn
sie schreiben in ihrem buch man könne
bäume auch als die menschen das
pflanzenreich sehen die uns helfen den
herzschlag der welt zu spüren
für mich klingt das eigentlich erst mal
ziemlich esoterisch worin gleichen sich
der mensch und pflanze so trügerisch ist
es sicher nicht weil wenn man die bäume
wissenschaftlich untersucht dann merkt
man schon ein paar parallelen zu
menschen das vegetative wachstum bevor
es blüht ist ein sehr langes und erst
nach 30 40 jahren machen die bäume
blüten und früchte und samen und dann
der die standhaftigkeit mit diesem
aufrechten wachstum mit dieser vertikal
itt ist auch mehr hat es ein symbol ist
ja wahrscheinlich überlebensstrategien
die auch mit ihm um stärke zu tun haben
sie haben ja ganz im mikrobiologischen
flora duschen diese jahrhunderte immer
sie wachsen
es ist sehr ähnlich wie
bei uns menschen dass uns auch so alt
werden lässt was ist denn die grenze
zwischen mensch und natur
was würden sie sagen also die grenze
zwischen mensch und natur das ist klar
die erreicht ranzen reich autohof das
heißt sich selbst zustands aufbauen mit
sondern nicht und hätte rot-rot pflanzen
brauchen zum selber erleben können
da ist ein gegensatz aber es gibt ein
paar ähnlichkeiten jetzt der puls das
thema puls alles was lebt pulsiert und
die bäume 2 genutzt aus auf der feinsten
weise unsere forschung hat zeigen können
dass sogar der baumstamm pulsiert und
wenn man den sondereffekt ein bisschen
wegnimmt abschirmt dann pulsiert der
baum im rhythmus des bundes der und
gezeiten und wie misst man dass das in
konz genaue messanlagen wird man 100
millimeter stammdurchmesser variationen
erfassen kann
und dann passieren die knospen der bäume
ist pulsiert
der elektrische strom in den stämmen wo
man elektronen einsetzen kann und was
man jetzt weiß die erde selber hat auch
strömen elektrische ströme und und
bewegungen geologische und man spricht
vom puls der erde das ist die so
genannte schumann frequenz zwischen 7
und 8 herz also eine frequenz mit 87
schlägen pro sekunde das ist sehr
langsam natürliche vorgänge
was kann der mensch von der natur von
bäumen von pflanzen lernen eben erstens
dass das alles pulsiert und das
eigentlich alles sind zusammenhang steht
mit dem größten umkreis dieser
verbindungen der bäume sind nicht nur
mit der hand sondern auch mit dem
kosmischen geschehen also mit dem
astronomischen geschehen die die
gezeiten habe ich erwähnt oder die
position des mondes im sternen
hintergrund als das wurde
wissenschaftlich dann validiert oder
festgestellt wie es die früheren kultur
und traditionsgemäß immer gesagt haben
wir sprechen damit auch etwas an weil
sie sagen ja dass der wald ein
organismus seien die bäume quasi
sozusagen einzelne organe dieses
organismus was geschieht denn konkret
mit dem wald wenn ich jetzt hier einen
baum fällen genau weil das organ ist
sehr wichtig das richtig zu verstehen
von außen gesehen ist ein weil die mal
geschlossen hat dann wirklich immer eine
hülle eine schutzhülle
das ist das wichtigste organ eines
organismus auch für die einzel ist die
zellmembran das wichtigste organ
bestimmte zellen brauchen gar keinen
zellkern aber eine membran gibt es ihm
also bald mit schutzhülle und der
besteht aus bäumen natürlich die
waldsaum pflanzen sind ein ist ein
anderer
auch beim ebt und der hauptwahl und
jetzt einen baum wird somit zum organ
des waldes der ein ganzes bildet und
innenraum und angst und raum sind dann
sehr unterschiedlich und jetzt für den
förster ein baum im wald entnehmen ist
nicht einfach ein individuum baumfällen
das ist ein teil des waldes wegnehmen
damit wieder mehr licht in der woche in
den wald kommt aber indem man das ganze
doch respektiert und das organismus
nicht stört sondern einzel weise aus
also herausnehmen der bäume aber viel
weiß man denn welche bäume man nehmen
kann und wo man also wo man den
organismus nicht stellt das ist sind
fünf jahre ausbildung als forstingenieur
wo man dann wirklich warnt berndt und
welche baumarten brauchen wie viel licht
wie wenig und wie viel kann man auf aus
dem wald heraus nehmen die nachhaltige
nutzung menü das ist alles mit jedes
förster jetzt wenn sie das erzählen geht
das alles zusammenhängt dieser
organismus dann wundere ich mich hatten
ein wald ein bewusstsein
also je mehr man die natur heran kommt
umso mehr merkt man das ist nicht
einfach eine eine grüne kulisse es das
sind sie stehe jetzt einmal so gesagt
die einen eigenen funktionieren haben
und wenn wir jetzt feststellen dass bei
klimatischen störungen plötzlich der
laut gegen das war das plötzlich
herabgesetzt wird die ausdrucksfähigkeit
des waldes plötzlich nicht mehr ganz da
ist dann kann man sich schon sagen der
wald hat vielleicht auch etwas mehr als
nur eine ansammlung von bäumen an sich
und in früheren kulturen hat man schon
von waldgeistern gesprochen das war in
kabul noch aber ist da bewusstsein dabei
da bin ich gar nicht abgeneigt
da soll sie prothese zu nehmen und so
ein organismus werden weil diese durch
sie das nicht ein bewusstsein haben
wenn man weiß wie lange wir welche
zeiträume muss so etwas sich immer
metaphysik und aufrechterhalten kann
können den bäumen kommunizieren können
wir das verstehen und können wir in
diese kommunikation mit eintreten
also ich will meinen kollegen
kommunizieren das wissen wir jetzt genau
über die wurzeln gas ausdünstungen mit
den kosmos fachkräfte die wir noch nicht
ganz genau verstehen aber wir merken das
phänomen bioelektrische es gibt
elektrische impulse die auf die bayern
wirken das wasser ist ja immer als
substanz dazwischen sehr wichtig also
wir kommunizieren untereinander
das ist klar eine jacke die angefressen
wird von einer kultur antilope meldet es
den nachbarn die auch ist dann dass die
konsistenz und die die die qualität des
laubes länder und damit ja und die lupe
weiter fressen geht
ich kann denn der mensch da eintreten
kann der mensch das verstehen was die
kommunizieren die bäume also kann der
mensch verstehen auch hier kann man sich
fragen wenn man ein bisschen zurückgeht
und langsam immer mehr respekt hat zu
den früheren kulturen
diese alten kulturen bei uns fahren er
sich die gelten
in amerika die indianer in afrika und so
weiter diese ur völker hatten eine art
kommunikation direkt mit der
pflanzenwelt die ihnen irgendwie
pflanzen geheimnisse mitteilte für mich
ist das natürlich vollständig offen
aber je mehr ich forschungen mache in
diese richtungen
umso mehr habe ich respekt von diesen
erfahrungen und stelle mir schon mal vor
dass auch einmal wissenschaftlich
verstanden wird und würden sie sagen
dass die natur beseelt ist wenn das geld
sein bedeutet dass sich etwas ausdrückt
und emotionen
von sich gibt dann kann man schon ganz
klar sagen es war ein wald als
organismus hat eine ganze menge von von
emotionen und die idee bekannt gegeben
werden
denken wir nur an die vogelwelt haben
die insektenwelt bevor man sieht es ist
eine einzel folge ließ war ein einzel
insekt das sind eigentlich
ausdrucksweisen des waldes auf einer
höheren ebene gesehen und beseelt hat
man den wall dem auferstandenen früheren
kulturen und je mehr ich mit solchen
sachen wissenschaftlich umgeht aber umso
mehr merke ich dass diese alten kulturen
erhellende wahrnehmungen hatten und so
habe ich das immer mehr als mögliche
prozesse was mich schon immer fasziniert
hat sich gleichmäßige frauen von tanz ab
aber auch von blättern und in ihrem buch
schreiben sehr über diese spiralförmig
kite als ein prinzip des lebens können
sie das erklären
ja das ist effektiv ein ganz schönes
gesetz soll der bau eines dann zapfen
seinen chören zockens ist extrem
geometrisch genau erkannt also jede
gruppe gehört rechtsorientierten
spiralen und einer links orientiert und
spirale und die summe der spielhallen
rechts oder links orientiert ist immer
ungleicher asymmetrisch und wenn man
alle den zapfen nimmt fichtenzapfen
führen zapfen lerchen zapfen dann kann
man eine bestimmte anzahl von spiralen
die sich immer wieder befindet 358 13 21
und jetzt hier haben wir acht und fünf
zb dann ist das verhältnis von zwei
nacheinander folgenden zahlen immer der
goldene schnitt
und dieses spiel haben sie auch
lebensprinzip genau das spielprinzip
findet man überall wo leben vorhanden
ist also stecken natürlich am
menschlichen körper am scheitern wie die
araber bilden das herz ist auch spiralig
aufgebaut die muskelfasern und auch das
wasser zeigt dieser spiralen die vortex
bildungen des wassers links oder rechts
und das ist wirklich ein prinzip das
durchstehen ist bei entspannungsmusik im
wellness zb hört man ja vogelgezwitscher
oder was er geräusche und im wald ist es
alles gewalt reagieren denn bäume auch
auf geräusche das weiß man jetzt auch
genau die vögel singen nicht nur um
territorium zu schützen oder abzugrenzen
jetzt weiß man dass das eine wirksamkeit
hat auf die aminosäuren synthese potenz
in these und man sogar bestimmte
sequenzen erkannt das ist sicher schon
die träume der schamanin saskia
mittendorf die mich erwartet ganz
herzlichen dank erzieher für ihre
ausführungen
inzwischen soll
[Musik]
[Applaus]
frau mittendorf sie haben gerade ein
germanisches trommer ritual gemacht wir
haben sie das genau vollzogen
ich habe er einen heiligen rahmen
gestaltet indem ich die
himmelsrichtungen hosted sie den westen
norden den himmel und die erde und alle
kräfte dazwischen die elemente feuer
wasser erde luft die pflanzen steine die
mineralien die tiere und die orden
kräfte eingeladen der im vorfeld gesagt
das ist etwas heiliges für sie weshalb
ist das heilig wir erschaffen da eine
ganzheit heinig von rooney etwas ganzes
dass es harmonisch wird dass wir hier
ein gutes wirklich stattfinden und was
geschieht mit ihnen dabei wenn sie das
machen und diese gesamtheit ein laden
mit der einladung der kräfte und dem
thema rhythmus
nicht mal bewusst weiter mich ausgehend
resonanz liegt allen kräften in dem
ideen und diesem ort und dann sehen sie
dass diesen ort ansatz
ich versuche mich über alle fünf sinne
auszuweiten und wahrzunehmen was ist da
auch noch und was ist ja auch noch
es ist ein ganz ruhiger energie sind
viele kräfte da viele auto abholen
kräfte sind um wesen kann man das nur in
der natur machen oder kann ich das auch
in meinem zimmer machen
sie können überall ein harmonisches
ritual gestalten ist einfach viel
einfacher in der freien natur weil alles
in der natur ist beseelt und wir
versuchen auf allen ebenen zu kommen
da sind wir verbunden und im zimmer ist
schon schwierig nur die luft den himmel
die kraft der sonne zu spielen weil
alles so weit entfernt ja sie haben das
jetzt ein bisschen angetönt eben
pflanzen tiere steine sogar das hat
alles eine sehr wichtige bedeutung für
sie können sie das erläutern weshalb es
für sie so wichtig ist für einen
schamanen so zentral der schamane öffnet
sich für die seele der natur weil auf
dieser ebene ist er verbunden
auf dieser ebene ist der l1 und der
hilft dem krieg renten sich auch wieder
zu öffnen weil dorfentwicklung und
heilung steckt also sie arbeiten eben
auch mit leuten zusammen bieten den
schamanische rituale an deswegen sagen
sie könnten ja ich arbeite mit einzelnen
leuten aber auch mit lupen und mit der
vision reisen und eben das um das
richtig zu verstehen dass schamane
verbindet sich mit der seele seine seele
verbindet sich mit der seele all dieser
einzelnen
dinge ist das richtig er sucht sich in
der natur verbündete die für heilung zu
wissen haben dass wir menschen nutzen
können ein schamane es doch auch ein
vermittler zwischen den welten sagt man
und von welchen werten sprechen wir da
ganz konkret ich habe hier die
alltägliche wirklichkeit die wir mit
unseren fünf sinnen wahrnehmen und
können uns öffnen für die anderswelt für
das was ist da auch noch außerhalb von
raum und zeit ich habe es eben wenn ich
sage ich verbinde ich bin eine
unsterbliche seele und da bin ich
verbunden mit allem auf erden moderierte
einem menschen helfen
man kennt ja auch den begriff des
gefällten baumes traditionell können sie
das erklären
der wählt den baum verbindet wunderbar
die tiefe vermutet ethos mit dem kosmos
streckt seine erste gang hinauf und wir
haben ja auch eine wirbelsäule die sich
auch so aufrichten und je nach klient
arbeitet auch mit diesem und den welten
der mittleren welt oder der oberen wind
lebensweisheit
es gibt diese bekannte schamanische
seelen reise reist man dann eben genau
durch diese welten wie sie jetzt gerade
erklärt haben oder was macht man bei
einer schamanischen seelen reise
traditionellerweise ist das eine
möglichkeit es gibt aber auch andere
möglichkeiten indem ich mich aus weiter
in den zwischenraum zwischen am horizont
gehen
den spalt öffnen das müssen sie erklären
das verstehe ich nicht wie man sie an
den horizont gehen zwischen himmel und
erde in den zwischen erbe in die pause
in die stille oder über die ordnung
einfach zu erklären
nachdem diese befreien
für diesen sport kann ich mich rufen
deshalb weiter für man
traditionellerweise auch in den
übergangszeiten und der dämmerung weil
es da einfacher ist okay und bei diesen
reisen haben sie doch oft auch ein kraft
dir dabei wenn ich richtig informiert
bin was haben sie denn für ein kraft dir
meine träume ist eigentlich auch
minecraft ihr ich nehme sie als mein
pferd um mich zu öffnen um mich in
diesem bewusstsein züchter und zu
bringen und ein ritual zu richten haben
sie auch andere kraft ihren kraft jede
sind ausdruck von energie entkräften und
je nach ritual besuchen wir haben die
kraft und die begleiten sie dann auf
diese reise und geben ihn quasi die
kraft um diese reise durchzuführen also
wenn sie im wasser sind dann haben sie
ein anderes tier als hier im wald die
tiere zeigen wir einfach die energie die
da ist und es geht darum in die kraft zu
kommen die in die freude zu kommen die
die lust am leben wie zu spüren
das beseelte wahrzunehmen
für schamanen ganz typisch ist ja dieses
initiation erlebnis und wie sind sie
denn überhaupt selber auf diesen
schamanischen weg bekommen gab es da
auch eine initiation erlebnis ich habe
als kind zu viel geträumt und nach der
geburt von meinen vier kindern wo ich in
kontakt kam mit der uhr lebenskraft mit
dieser starken energie da ich mich mit
der verbinden kann
und es entsteht etwas wunderbares daraus
kaum auch das träumen wieder stärker in
den vordergrund
und ich habe immer dann auch eine
ausbildung gemacht
und was macht man was lernt man das ist
ich träume jede nacht ich träume auch
viel deswegen bin ich keiner schamanen
sie sind auch ich traue mir häufig vor
dass ich weiß dinge im voraus weil ich
so geträumt habe
und ich bin heute morgen aufgewacht mit
gab es von meister eckhart der spruch
wer für ein bild aus und drehte hinein
wie verstehen sie das ist der traum
ausleben oder das leben
ganz herzlichen dank frau mit für dieses
gespräch
erleben sie sind philosoph und biologen
haben jüngst dieses buch her geschrieben
in die generalität dann sagen sie dass
unser weltbild zu einem ende gekommen
sei da frage ich mich welches weltbild
denn und würden solche überlegungen und
überzeugungen wie sie das könnten dort
mitgeteilt hat eine alternative bieten
das weltbild das an sein ende kommt ist
der journalismus und der dualismus heißt
dass wir den menschen als gesondert vom
rest der beliebten welt oder auch vom
rest des kosmos betrachten und damit
geht wirklich eine lange
geistesgeschichte geschichtliche epoche
zu ende
das ist noch nicht überall angekommen
das ist jetzt sozusagen gerade der
anfang aber es ist eine fundamentale
wandlung in unserem selbstverständnis
und das selbstverständnis ist dass sich
abzeichnet ist das eine zugehörigkeit
einer gegenseitigkeit einer
durchdringung mit der welt die wir
bisher immer als die natur bezeichnet
haben und was wir eben gesehen haben ist
ein versuch diese neue welt sich die
eigentlich auch eine sehr alte weltsicht
ist das nämlich sie meinen bei frauen
hätten genau genau der dass nämlich der
mensch in einem verhältnis der dereinst
eingefügt science in eine belebte welt
steht irgendwie wieder neu greifbar zu
machen das ist natürlich schwierig denn
die tradition auf die man sich da
beziehen kann sind entweder in anderen
kulturen zu finden oder aber in der
prähistorie und bekennen sie nicht und
dadurch entstehen dann immer mischungen
die sozusagen irgendwie neu erfunden
werden und aber wir sehen dabei den
versuch eine 1 verbunden seien wieder zu
reaktivieren
was ist denn für sie die natur sie haben
uns gerade angesprochen
die natur gibt es einmal in der sandra
mainstream version die wir über sie
gesprochen haben oder sprechen und dann
ist das die welt der anderen lebewesen
die welt des unbeliebten jedenfalls eine
welt die anders funktioniert als der
mensch
nämlich vor allen dingen als ressource
und als objekt gedacht und der mensch
ist derjenige der der natur immer
gegenüber steht auch der natur in sich
selbst als körper weil er nämlich über
subjektivität und sprache verfügt das
ist das alte bild wenn sie mich jetzt
fragen was ist natur dann kann ich ihnen
auch das neue bild versuchen zu
beschreiben und das nicht toll ist das
schlicht ballistische bild und dann ist
da muss man eigentlich aufhören von
natur zu sprechen weil dann hat man
dieses alte schema immer drin und dann
würde ich eher vom von der lebendigen
wirklichkeit sprechen oder vom reich der
lebendigkeit und das ist eine ein
prozess einer gegenseitigen
durchdringung die individuen gebiert die
sich nach entfaltung sehnen und dadurch
auf andere individuen angewiesen sind
also eine welt der gegenseitigkeit die
immer ein erleben ist die immer
emotional ist und der mann immer ob man
will oder nicht und wir auch als
menschen teil hat sie sagen ja auch wir
haben vergessen was es heißt zu leben da
frage ich mich natürlich weshalb wissen
sie es denn was bedeutet es überhaupt zu
leben
ja ich weiß es weil ich lebe und sie
wissen es auch weil sie auch leben und
jedes wesen weiß oder weiß ist
vielleicht schon zu menschlich gesagt
spürt erfährt was es heißt am leben zu
sagen jedes wesen und das können wir
auch den wesen anschauen drängt zum
eigenen sein hin zur eigenen entfaltung
zur blüte und hat entsprechend auch eine
erfahrung wie gut das funktioniert also
eine erfahrung von gut oder schlecht
eine erfahrung von gelingen oder
misslingen die wir auch aus uns selber
sehr gut kennen aber sie sagen sie
wissen dass ich weiß es deswegen kommt
es denn vergessen
das ist eine frage auf die ich jetzt nur
vermutungen äußern kann das ist glaube
ich eine der entscheidenden fragen die
wir uns stellen müssen und das ist eine
frage auf die ich immer wieder stoße
wenn ich über diese themen über meine
themen spreche wie ist es eigentlich
dazu gegeben das ist natur philosophie
kann ich ja mein thema ist eigentlich
die frage wie
können wir diese welt als lebendig so
verstehen dass wir sie zugleich
anschlussfähig an unsere
wissenschaftliche diskussion halten ich
bin ja selbst biologe also wir können
wir so habe ich angefangen wie können
wir die biologie das bild vom leben so
verstehen dass wir lebewesen als
subjekte mit erfahrungen verstehen
können und die frage wie ist es
eigentlich so gekommen
das wäre vergessen dass wir es vergessen
haben die ist das ist wirklich ein also
mit einem riesigen großen fragezeichen
versehen und ich kann dazu nur ein paar
stationen benennen also ein relevanter
schritt war sicherlich im antiken
griechenland zurzeit von platon als
entschieden wurde auf die ratio zu
setzen und es gibt diese wunderbare
szene in einem der platonischen dialoge
wie sokrates zu seinen schülern sitzt
draußen vor der stadt in der natur und
sagt die bäume sie haben für uns keine
bedeutung mehr was die bäume wissen hat
für uns keine bedeutung mehr
und das ist in diesem platonischen
dialog nachgezeichnet ist der abschied
von einem weltbild in dem alles andere
so ist wie wir alles andere also auch
lebt und alles andere auch person ist
wie ist das gekommen
eine vermutung ist es gab die hoffnung
dass wir wenn wir uns auf unsere
rationale kontrolle verlassen den tod
abschaffen und wir jagen dem immer noch
nach und sehen erleben gerade dass wir
ihnen vielleicht auf diese weise immer
wieder auf neue je nach epoche
unterschiedliche art und weise erst
recht einladen aber das wäre eine idee
ist dass die die hoffnung wir nehmen das
selbst in die hand und sind dann nicht
mehr sterblich
ihr angestrebtes neues weltbild hängt
eben sehr stark auch mit diesem begriff
in die realität zusammen können sie das
erläutern was meint dann in die
generalität ja das ist ein erstmal
natürlich ein wortspiel das viel
verspricht also es geht darum dass die
indigenen kulturen etwas geniales haben
und auch etwas was unsere kultur
vielleicht gerade jetzt dringend
brauchen
ganz kurz global zusammengefasst kann
man sagen und das schließt an die an
ihre frage von nebenan das in unserer
zivilisation schon lange eine
fundamentale regeln gilt und die regel
könnte man vielleicht beschreiben mit
versuche unter allen umständen deinen
tod zu vermeiden und in die indigenen
kultur und gilt eine andere regel und
die lautet alles lebt und deswegen
versuche unter allen umständen in
gemeinsamkeit das leben zu nehmen das
leben zu bewahren und so ist also das
erste erste wichtige punkt wenn man sich
indigene kulturen anguckt es gibt ja
noch ein paar und finden natürlich auch
historisch sehr viele das alles als
belebt gilt und dass man mit all dem was
belebt es auch irgendwie kommunizieren
kann
das zweite ist das ist auch sehr wichtig
es gilt alles als eine gegenseitige
hervorbringung von fruchtbarkeit
das heißt indigene machen nicht ihr ding
und nutzen ressourcen sondern in die
gene befinden sich in einer
gegenseitigkeit man würde mit dem alten
deutschen wort sagen in einer alm ende
kommen sagt man heutzutage also in einer
gemeinen güterwirtschaft in der sie
beschenkt werden mit dem was sie zum
leben brauchen und dann was zurückgeben
müssen ja und diese gegenseitigkeit ist
natürlich auch eine idee die uns
vielleicht nützen kann
sie schreiben ja auch und das hört man
schon raus mit diesen indigenen dass wir
wieder wild werden müssen
jetzt habe ich mich aber gefragt wenn
sie das sagen und wir sehen das virtual
reality ein wichtiges schlagwort
geworden ist digitalisierung also starke
artifiziell ii sierung man angst hat vor
keimen et cetera
wie soll man da hin wieder zurückkommen
ja das ist auch eine von diesen fragen
die sich jetzt stellen
wichtig ist erst mal so sehen wenn ich
sage wir sind eigentlich alle wild was
natürlich ein bisschen eine provokation
ist dass unter diesem bild nicht das
wild verstanden ist des hedonistischen
der sagt lebe wild und gefährlich
auch mal richtig drauf hol dir das was
zu holen ist sondern wild heißt dass wir
verstehen können dass wir eigentlich
unseren platz fruchtbar zu sein bereits
kennen dass unser körper ihn kennt dass
ökosysteme wissen wie gegenseitigkeit
funktioniert und dass es etwas gibt was
wir normalerweise ausschalten nämlich
eine form von emotionaler stimme die uns
sagen kann ob eigentlich mein leben so
wie ich es für richtig
insofern ist dieses bild natürlich ein
es ist eben nicht das bild das wir lange
jahre jahrhundert jahrzehnte für die
wildnis benutzt haben als der ort des
totalen chaos
also was ist denn hier was wieso seid
ihr seid jetzt nicht so wild oder so
sagt man seinen kindern wenn sie gerade
alles mögliche anstellen also das ist
eine idee von wildnis die entstanden ist
in der zeit in der man sich
verabschiedet hat davon dass die bäume
etwas zu sagen haben und damit hat man
etwas ausgegrenzt was auch in uns selbst
steckt mit denen uns selbst gibt es ja
sehr viel wild heißt also wir sind
eigentlich wild wenn wir geboren werden
in dem moment ich habe zwei kinder
ich erinnere mich genau an den moment
der geburt meines sohnes als der auf
einmal vor mir lag ja und ich wusste
jetzt bin ich in der wildnis na ja also
das ist was natürlich etwas was uns
menschen immer noch genau so passiert
wie uns das vor 50.000 jahren passiert
ist
also das fundamentale basale körperlich
leben erleben spüren im gegenseitigkeit
das war eine extreme gegenseitigkeit
situation ich habe ein kind ja das ist
alles noch sagen wir eine eine art und
weise wie wir lebendig sind ohne dass
wir uns einen überbau geben und und da
haben wir auch dazu haben wir gefühle
und diese gefühle leiden wenn wir uns
dazu entscheiden auf all das nicht mehr
zu achten und was sie beschrieben haben
diese aktivität
das ist ja gerade darum gefährlich weil
es sich abkoppelt von dem was unsere
ureigenen bedürfnisse sind und es
koppelt sich natürlich auch ab weil es
eine sagen wir eine kommerzielle kohle
realisierung einiger weniger ist die
denen es gar nicht um menschsein zu tun
ist sondern um bereicherung
was sie zu beginn gesagt haben das führt
er auch so ein bisschen auf einen
animismus hin ich habe vor vielen jahren
auf dem bahnhof in göschenen diese
fragen hier gefunden
flüsternd der berg schläft er hört der
bergwand er sinkt der berg träumte er
das ist ein kunstwerk von sonya kraus
und da frage ich sie
was sind ihre antworten auf diese fragen
ja gefällt mir sehr gut ich bin habe ich
mir gedacht ich bin ja auch deswegen
weil sie löschen dann sagen und ich
erinnere mich an die kindheits reisen
nach italien die immer die courtage
strecke entlang finden und insofern ist
für mich so eine station der verheißung
und es erinnert mich noch an etwas
anderes nehmen wir es auch eine
verheißung
diese fragen ja es gefällt mir gut ist
ist erinnert mich an etwas das mir noch
besser gefällt nämlich ein topos aus dem
aus der amerikanischen öko philosophie
von alt und leopold der sagt dass wir
wieder lernen sollten so zu denken wie
ein berg thinking the mountain sind eine
ganz wichtige eine ganz wichtige
konfiguration in der ökologischen
philosophie und muss man sich eben
fragen das kann man sich bei diesem
gesicht gedicht natürlich auch fragen
was heißt das eigentlich denken wie ein
berg was ist das eigentlich die
anfeindungen haben dann pflanzen und
steine emotion ja solcherlei ja also
ganz wichtig ist dass wir bevor wir uns
an die beantwortung dieser frage machen
dass wir erst mal gucken wie reagieren
wie eigentlich wenn wir uns dem denken
eines berges aussetzen und das denken
eines berges und das ist bei alu leopold
auch sehr deutlich dass besteht erst mal
aus all den lebenden wesen die sich in
diesem berg auf diesem berg als dieser
berg begegnen und immer wieder neu
fruchtbar hervorbringen das heißt ein
werk denkt zum beispiel in farben weil
er sich im herbst mit dem herbstlaub
verändert ein berg denkt in form der
arten die auf ihm leben und sich
vermehren und sich verändern und
schwanken
ein berg denkt anders wenn wir den wolf
aus den weltweit eliminieren oder wenn
eine neue blumen art hinzu kommt das ist
alles das denken des berges aber wenn
wir das denken
dann kann man sich ja schon fragen ob
das nicht schon eine schwärmerische
entgleisung eben unsere kenntnisse ist
ja das kann man sich fragen ja und das
ist wäre jetzt also bis zu sagen bis vor
wenigen jahren wo diese ganze
selbstverortung auf dieser welt ins
rutschen gekommen ist wäre das
eigentlich auch die standard antwort
gewesen und ist es sie ist es immer noch
also dieses diese idee dass wir im
zugang haben können
zu dem was leben ist das nicht unser
leben ist und was sich aber auch zeigt
in seinen bedürfnissen und in seiner
seinem ausdruck von lebendigkeit und dem
bedürfnis fruchtbar zu sein das wäre
verneint worden das wird es auch immer
noch das ist also hoch kontrovers
worüber ich hier spreche ich habe jetzt
ganz bewusst deswegen im angefangen mit
der öko philosophie also leopold das ist
sozusagen noch in die in das romantische
in die romantische sichtweise irgendwie
rein zu bringen also wir sehen den
herbst und das ist nehmen wir als das
denken des berges war also eine weise
des lebens sich zu präsentieren die wir
von innen her verstehen können aber man
kann natürlich jetzt
weiter gehen und sagen dieser berg ist
in diesem denken vielleicht ein wesen
ja und das wäre sozusagen jetzt dann
klarer stärker animismus und es gibt
viele anthropologen die uns mittlerweile
im dringend nahe legen dass wir solche
denkfiguren die tatsächlich dann aus dem
denken animistisch noch immer
animistisch funktionierender völker
stammen
das mal genauer anschauen anschauen
sollten weil sie vielleicht die
wirklichkeit besser darstellen als
unsere
dann hast du dich fragen was ist denn
gewonnen wenn wir eine animistische
sicht vertreten wie sie jetzt ja
teilweise auch tun in diesem teil
ja ja also ich glaube es ist sehr viel
gewonnen es ist nämlich als erstes
gewonnen dass unsere eigenen eindrücke
nicht mehr an der welt abprallen
normalerweise wie sieht das grab
zugesagt haben ja das ist doch aber
alles projektionen ja da steht der
mensch vor der pracht anderen lebens und
muss sich selbst sagen das ist alles
einbildung und die wahrnehmung der
schönheit das ja wissen jedoch
mindestens seit kann dass es ja durchaus
von mensch vermutlich in die natur
hineingelegt werden sagen sie das ist
nicht so oder wieder genau das sage ich
und kannte ich sage auch dass kant an
der stelle zu revidieren ist ich bin
nicht der einzige
das ist jetzt auch eine gerade eine
schwere zeit verkannt weil kann
natürlich diese einer der der
philosophen weiter diese band in die
wirklichkeit gezogen und und das sind
alles immer überlegungen die ohne
unseren körper agiere
ja das sind alles philosophie die davon
ausgehen dass wir eine filmkamera haben
die außen reize auf eine leinwand
projiziert und das ist unser geist wir
sind längst schon mit einem körper in
der landschaft und dieser körper atmet
und er atmet ein und einem partner aus
und das was er aus atmet das atmen die
bäume ein
die auf diesem berg stehen zum beispiel
aber sie haben mich ja sie habe ich was
anderes gefragt bevor wir diesen kleinen
schlenker zu bekannt gemacht aber das
war aber wichtig dass wir das gemacht
haben
ich habe mich gefragt warum ist das
wichtig warum ist die animistische sicht
wichtig ja genau was da dadurch geworden
ja dadurch sind weil man nimmt ja diese
also animismus kommt der anima die seele
da auch letztlich deswegen muss man da
gleich die seele mit einkaufen ein
weiteres metaphysisches phänomen idee
also animismus heißt im weitesten sinne
alles ist subjektiv belebt oder alles
ist beseelt das heißt nicht unbedingt
alles ist mit der christlichen seele
sozusagen begabt das heißt das nicht
unbedingt vom begriffe aber ich will ich
will das noch mal einen holen also
einerseits finden wir uns selber in
einer welt wieder in der wir die nicht
unsere projektion ist sondern die uns
wirklich antwortet zweitens ist es so
dass eine welt die selber lebt oder der
philosoph bruno latour würde sagen die
akteur ist eine solche welt kann auch
eine rolle in politischen entscheidungen
haben und bruno latour ist jemand einer
der großen der diesen animismus als
philosophisches und sogar politisches
programm aktiviert und er sagt ja ja ja
ja ja die sind ihnen die göttin der
hatte aber die eben auch in dieser
wissenschaftlichen theorie von live blog
sozusagen als die zelte also der die die
sich subjektiv selbst organisieren und
erhalten der erde nimmt bruno latour
wirklich zur überraschung von vielen
auch zu meiner sagte wir müssen jetzt
einfach sehen dass da ja ein akteur
geworden ist und ein akteur hat eine
politische stimme und das problem der
ökologie in all diesen jahren ist
gewesen dass sie die rechte von objekten
vertreten hat
umweltschützer haben die rechte von
dingen vertreten rechtlich sind
braunkehlchen die man schützen möchte in
einem auf einem trockenrasen sind
objekte sind dinge und deswegen müssen
die verrechnet werden gegen andere dinge
und da ziehen sie immer den kürzeren
das ist ein schwerwiegender vorteil ja
das ist ein großer vorteil
wir sagen diese lebende welt ist ein akt
und ich glaube das kann doch gar nicht
aus was das eigentlich bedeutet also
dass ein akteur in dem sie uns antwortet
und sie ist ein akteur in dem wir mit
ihrer bündnisse schmieden können gegen
eine immer weniger gegenseitigkeit und
egalität uns schenkende wenn ich habe
gelesen dass sie im frühling jeden tag
mit ihrem rad in den grunewald nach
berlin sieben leben ja in berlin
gefahren sind zu ihrer eiche
was macht diese eiche denn so speziell
für sie diese einhält dabei ja das ist
sehr schön in kriege ich jetzt gleich
was empfinden sie eines extra heimweh
hat diese leiche diese eiche ist ein
werden auch eichen in der schweiz
ich weiß ich weiß ich habe ja auch meine
eigenen erfahrung ist in der schweiz
also diese ich würde fast sagen ist ein
mentor
was lehrt sie sie denn sie lehrt mich
das zum leben das ergrünen und die
schlummernde todes ähnliche ruhe
gleichermaßen gehört sie lehrt mich dass
ein einzelner niemals nur ein einzelner
ist sondern immer viele wie es goethe
schon gesagt hat den eichen sind die
bäume die die meisten ökologischen
beziehungen haben in unseren
mitteleuropäischen ökosystemen und
eichen sind vor allen dingen bäume die
sehr alt werden können dabei aber
gleichzeitig schon so halb zersetzt foul
also in dieser eiche leben von dessen
selbst bezeugt und spechte und meisen
und es gibt fantastische riesengroße
bock käfer die in diesem wald pflegen
weil sie das alte eichenholz fressen
also diese eiche ist für mich ein ort
der fruchtbarkeit und sie ist ein
ratgeber weil sie zeigt was fruchtbar
sein heißt das ist wirklich für mich
eine immer wieder erneuerte erfahrung
ich war sehr erstaunt sie haben in
demselben text auch geschrieben dass sie
eben die eiche dann auch ihre
zukünftigen jetzigen frau gezeigt
vorgestellt haben
und dann haben sie zusammen eine eiche
gepflanzt in diesem wald illegalerweise
vermutlich sollen nicht wo sie
beschreiben das wie ein wenn ich mich
richtig
leidenschaftlicher langer kurs ja genau
es war eine fruchtbarkeit zeremonie ja
genau also hatten wir diese kleine eiche
dann zum geburtstag geschenkt weil wir
uns eben letztlich in dem wald kennen
gelernt haben also unsere ersten dates
hatten wir im wald und nicht in einem
auf einer kaffeetasse und wir sie hat
mir diese kleine eiche geschenkt und
winter hat sie dann erstmal eine weile
auf dem balkon gestanden weil der boden
gefroren war und dann haben wir uns
entschlossen ihr seid jetzt müssen wir
die pflanzen weil sonst ist es zu spät
und na ja wir haben diese eiche in einer
ganz ähnlichen aktion den dem boden
geschenkt und dann dieses loch gegraben
mit den händen und haben wir mussten ja
oder völlig sein wir hatten kein
schweres gerät dabei und das war schon
ein bisschen ein kuss für eine berührung
so eine gegenseitigkeit das war wirklich
ein bisschen spüren dass wir selbst auf
eine ganz ganz einfache schlichte und
immer wieder neue art und weise zur erde
gehören
und also das war sozusagen miterlebt und
gleichzeitig bezeugt weil wir dabei
waren weil wir jetzt gemeinsam gemacht
haben und dann kam dieser schreckliche
sommer und deswegen habe ich die eiche
jeden tag begossen
da sind immer raus ich oder meine frau
aber meistens ich oder wir beide aber
ich weil ich der weil ich die meerwasser
tragen konnte also ich habe das dann auf
dem fahrrad transportiert oder im
rucksack
wir haben diese eiche gepäppelt weil sie
sonst vertrocknet wäre jetzt hat es
geschafft und jetzt gibt es sozusagen
eine neue saison los
ja das ist für mich ist das eine
erfahrung wie ein kuss weil es eben eine
erfahrung des aufblühenden und der
grünen es ist und zu blühen ist bewusst
zu sein ist für mich die valent ja der
patron der ökologie zumindest in der
kirche ist ja franz von assisi der
gründer des franziskaner orden
und er sagt ja eigentlich das uns aus
jedem wesen gott entgegen leuchtet und
er hat deswegen auch mitunter zum
beispiel vögeln die evangelien gepredigt
ja muss man denn auch die natur erlösen
ist auch die natur erlösung bedürftig
genauso wie der mensch ja ich glaube
nicht also im gegenteil der mensch ist
gerade sehr erlösung bedürftig ich
bewundere vieles von ihm sehr der natur
die evangelien zu lesen dass wenn ich
dann ein bisschen die umkehrung ist
dessen was sozusagen eigentlich
angezeigt wäre aber nichtsdestoweniger
ist in seiner haltung ja etwas drin was
ein immer wieder wundern lässt dass er
das überhaupt überstanden hat in dieser
zeit ist des christentums in seiner
blüte nämlich zu sagen dass alles was
sich leben verbindet teil gottes ist ja
das ist sehr radikal
das ist eigentlich radikale christliche
mystik die sich dann nahtlos anschließen
lässt an mächtigen anderer religionen in
der mystik sind religion kommen sich
sehr nahe und kommen auch wieder dem
indigenen verständnis sehr nahe und das
nämlich alles was in dieser welt ist
ausdruck eines schöpfungs begehrens ist
aus sich heraus und insofern immer auch
irgendwie heilig das ist ja sehr stark
auch vertreten in indigenen haltung kann
auch nicht laut reden wenn der berg
zugehört weil er eben nur würde voll
angesprochen werden kann
mir scheint insgesamt bei ihren
ausführungen dass jedoch die natur auch
sehr glorifizieren
dann kann man aber natürlich die
gegenseite einwänden seien krankheiten
wo die ganzen bakterien mann überlebt
nur genau überlebt nur weil etwas
anderes sein leben hingibt eben ist es
nicht zu optimistisch bin froh dass sie
mir wirklich die fragen stellen die
gestellt werden müssen und die
notorischen fragen und mir passiert ist
dass je nach dem wie ich die geschichte
erzähle man mehr entweder sagt ich
glorifizieren die natur oder aber man
sagt mir ich zeichne ein zu düsteres
bild weil ich immer vom tod sprechen
das entscheidende an dem moment der
gegenseitigkeit ist dass wir darin in
unser eigenes sterben einwilligen
ökosysteme als große allmende sind auch
nahrungsketten und ich sagte ja schon am
anfang auf ihre frage etwas nachdenklich
wieso ist es eigentlich wie ist es
eigentlich dazu gekommen dass wir uns
davon abgewandt haben das war die idee
dass wir dem tod davonlaufen können
und selbstverständlich ist der
zusammenhang des lebens ein dauerndes
geboren werden und ein dauerndes sterben
und gleichwohl ist es ein dauerndes
geboren werden und nicht eben nur der
tod aber es ist total klar also ich sage
eigentlich immer sehr gerne dass wenn
wir wirklich lebendig sein wollen dann
müssen wir uns essbar machen im essbar
sein
ich weiß nicht wie glorifizieren sich
das jetzt anhört aber es war sein dass
erhalt uns ja alle am ende unseres
lebens
dann werden wir gegessen und schenken
uns zurück diesem großen gloriosen
kreislauf den wir die ganze zeit schon
angehören
man könnte aber auch ganz böse sagen
dass aufgrund dieser ganzen
klimakatastrophe was letztlich auch ihre
spray plädoyer aufs tapet holt die er
hat einfach auf unser verschwinden
wartet und eigentlich sind wir die
missetäter die natur kommt gut ohne uns
zu recht ja ich meine so wie sie die
frage stellen haben wir wieder zwei
seiten da gibt es die natur und den
menschen ich habe habe ich nicht
verstehen
nein es ist ich mache das auch bauen
weil uns das sehr schwer fällt wenn
diese hoffnung dass ihnen jetzt ja ja
unser also dass die natur ist ja ein
begriff der ist geprägt worden in einer
bestimmten haltung und wir benutzen ihn
deswegen ist es wichtig dass man sich
selber immer wieder darauf aufmerksam
macht dass ich sagen will ist wir können
jetzt aus einer system perspektive sagen
wir sind eine außerordentlich
erfolgreiche art die dabei ist ihre
eigenen ressourcen zu verbrauchen und
weiß dass aus der biologie dass das
irgendwann zu einem
population zusammenbruch führt und so
kann man das sich angucken also so ist
sozusagen die kann man die geschichte
erzählen und im augenblick sieht es so
aus als würde ist alles ein bisschen
enger und ein bisschen knapper jetzt
habe ich gerade gehört das 70 jahre
schneller als erwartet der permafrost in
kanada auftaut wir sind leider fast
schon am ende unseres gesprächs wir
könnten auch sehr lange weiter reden und
ich hätte auch noch sehr viele fragen
dann sehe ich aber eine allerletzte
frage die sie deswegen auch ganz sehr
kurz bitte beantworten wenn sie die
möglichkeit hätten zum baum der
erkenntnis oder vom baum des lebens die
frucht zu nehmen welche würden sie
nehmen
ich nehme die frucht vom baum des lebens
die ganze zeit täglich dauernd und
insofern ja deinen kw dafür dieses
gespräch ebenfalls findet die frage was
bewusstsein überhaupt ist gehört wohl zu
den ältesten fragen der philosophie
barbara bleisch sucht mit dem
australischen philosophen david charles
nach dem bewusstsein und fragt könnte es
nicht sein dass alle um uns herum nur
zombies sind auf wiedersehen
[Musik]